food had mine on
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the July council meeting for the gore
District Council
just as we get underway today I'd like
to welcome and introduce councilor elect
Andy Fraser who is joining us here today
to participate in the conversation if he
wishes but for members of the public
just to highlight he doesn't have voting
rights until he is sworn in but welcome
Andy welcome to the team and I'm sure
you'll thoroughly enjoy some of the
things that are ahead of us
um so today
um I'll start with the apologies we've
got apologies from mayor Ben Bell uh
councilor Richard mcphail and councilor
glennis Dixon and all others uh present
if I can have a mover and a secondary
for the apologies please
ah right thank you Dean
okay so I've got a mover for Richard and
glennist then from Joe and uh from
Neville Phillips are there any
Declarations of council or conflicts of
interest for today
there appear to be none we have two
items in the agenda today and I'm
actually going to reverse the order of
them so that the key item which is the
proposed District plan is able to be
dealt with and um
anyone interested in the other one will
deal with that first so there's a report
from myself with regard to the future of
the local government report that appears
on page 9 and 10 as counselors will be
aware the report has now been released
and at the mail Forum
there was a desire for two from each
Council to come together
to prepare a reply to that for later in
the year are there any questions that
arise from what's in that report and
comments take them both at the same time
so there are three recommendations that
accompany the report one that the report
be received to that the mayor and Deputy
Mayor represent the gore District
Council on the south regional working
part at a party to consider the future
of the local government report and and
three that the council delegate to the
mayor and Deputy Mayor authority to
approve a submission to the government
on behalf of the four Southland councils
can I hit a mover for that please Paul
oh sorry yes Paul
yes
thank you again
um just does this come back to us before
the submission goes away
um we will certainly circulate a copy
informally to councils before it goes
away but depending on the timing of
meetings uh the formal sign off might
require at a later date hence the
recommendation that's there to
delegate lodging the submission to the
mayor and Deputy map because it's quite
quite a few contentious issues there as
far as who come together who put this
together
this report was it the your air mural
former Forum or was it it flows from the
mayoral forum and the proposal that we
were intending to move forward with but
uh it's open in fact discussion okay
right thank you
yes
okay yeah
um just to clarify the points that are
listed on page
um nine
which are the the 245 bullet points are
matters that are contained in the
um report on from the review panel
so they're not my thoughts on on where
it should be heading and thank you to
the chief executive yes
okay that's what I was thinking because
they don't some of them don't look like
they're
possibly from the smaller regions or has
been and there's a few issues there that
I think we need to go over but
I'm happy for you to discuss those
issues with um The Forum as far as it
goes but I just want to make this all it
will will endeavor to discuss it as much
as we can okay thank you
so any other feedback comments
so if I can have a mover and secondary
for the three recommendations please
come comes from Bronwyn and a second
from Stuart
all those in favor say aye
against carried
returning to item three which is the
proposed District plan
there was a report there from the
planning consultants and I'm sure you've
all read the report they think it's most
unlikely that you've read the 600 pages
and fall off the district plan document
one counselor and one member of the
public both have their hand up but to
make it easy for the rest of us
I've asked the Consultants to give us a
brief presentation of the key matters
that are in it and um will proceed from
there so to
Mason his team were in your hands
uh thank you Council haval
um we're just going to run through a
correct presentation but before I do
we'll just do some quick introductions
because this has been a real team effort
both from the property group uh as well
as the district and subcommittee in the
room number as well
um so I'm Matt heal I'm the principal
planner at the property group I've been
managing the district pen review next to
me is Mishka on screen we've got uh we
had
Victoria and Tina and Katrina as well
and Joe and so we're just going to do a
bit of a tag team presentation to you
basically we're going to provide an
overview of how we got to where we are
some key changes between the the current
District Plan and the New Plan and the
next steps so if we just go to the next
slide
just a very brief background as you're
probably aware the district plans the
community's rule book that outlines what
people can do as a right
and what they need a resource consent
for
we've been working uh on reviewing the
plan with the council and the Rooney for
some time now
it's been fairly tested by the community
Through the draft District plan
consultation around last year
we've worked with the district plan
subcommittee to now make changes So the
plan is ready for no notification and
reflects largely Community aspirations
the councils appointed a hearing panel
to consider formal submissions from the
public so we're ready to notify the plan
it's the next slide
um
we need to review the plan in accordance
with the requirements of the resource
management act every 10 years so this is
a must-have from a statutory perspective
the Pro's plan reflects the current
Regional and National Direction
and it's fit for purpose and that it
reflects land use change on the ground
that has occurred over the last 20 years
since the original plan was notified or
made operative
we're ensuring the right types of
activities are provided for in the right
place so for example
industrial activities are happening in
the industrial Zone not in the middle of
a residential zone for example
the objectives and policies in the plan
reinforce this approach and the rule
framework is more targeted to the types
of effects
that Council planners should be
considering so we've moved away from
Full discretionary activities to
restricted discretionary activities
typically so
for example if you've got a daylight
infringement where you might be shading
the neighbor the focus is on the shading
effects as opposed to the color you
might paint your house for example
just go to the next slide
we'll go through the the key zoning
changes in a bit more detail shortly
these are outlined on page three and
four of the agenda but overall the new
zones which are required by the national
planning standards provide for New
Growth areas in terms of industrial
growth and residential growth
and align with land use land use is
occurring on the ground today as I've
noted
it's moving to the next slide
this is really about the plan structure
so that the plan is in four key parts
the first part the introduction on the
top left
um
gives an introduction to the plan but it
also has key elements such as the the
definition so the plan's easy to
interpret
the second part of the plan
covers the district-wide chapters
that address a wide range of topics from
our the Strategic direction to managing
our key natural resources and social and
physical infrastructure that the
national planning standards require us
to cover
and then we've got in the the dark green
color there the zones and and this is
the objectives and policies and rules
that clearly articulate what we're
trying to achieve in those different
areas
and there's a summary of of those
outcomes on page three of the agenda
and then the fourth part of the plan are
the maps where these zones are shown
and these natural features are
identified
next slide please thank you
so we undertook some public engagement
last year and we got a broad range of
feedback from quite a broad range of
stakeholders most of those changes were
adopted particularly if it resulted in
improved Clarity or achieved Regional
and National direction there's some
details of that on page four and six of
the agenda but as an example we
originally had three media yard setbacks
but it wasn't clear for the plan user if
that meant minimum maximum you know so
we tweaked that to make it clearer and
then some natural hazards we had
originally upzone some more areas but it
was shown that they weren't viable for
my natural hazards flooding perspective
yeah make slime please
cool this might be a little bit hard to
read but as a general sort of shows
we're trying to put the right activities
in the right place so the fourth bullet
point of
um page two of the agenda kind of gives
an example but as you know residential
activities and residential areas
industrial within industrial areas so
you can see there that yeah residential
activities and residential zones certain
commercial zones with some standards
multi-purpose owned rural zones Etc but
discouraged in industrial zones as an
example
next slide I think the people on Zoom
are really struggling to hear that might
have since been sold but they might not
be able to actually hear this
if there's anyone on Zoom able to hear
you this
right okay well I might just cover this
slide
um
so
basically what we're going to highlight
here is some key changes between the the
operative District plan and the proposed
plan that we presented to you today so
largely in the rural area we've
introduced three zones whereas currently
the operative plan has one been rural
Zone
um we've introduced settlement zones and
um pokerau Mandeville and waikaka and
they basically provide for the types of
activities that occurring in those zones
at the moment to at the scale that
they're appearing so the rural Zone at
the moment
for example
provides for limited subdivision a lot
of the sites and these settlements are a
lot smaller than their subdivision
standard so the settlement zones provide
for those activities
some of the other key changes that we've
provided for a rural lifestyle zone
around Mandeville and waikaka which is
largely where we've got some of those
smaller rural sites and a rural
lifestyle zone around the hokanui hills
to reflect development that's happening
there currently
so that's a quick overview of the rural
areas
if we move to the next slide
I don't know if we can get Joe so I
might just continue on
so so I guess as an overarching approach
we've probably introduced a lot more
color to gore than you've had previously
so you had a five zones we've got
something between 18 and 20 zones now
and in Gore we've got an industrial
growth here into the South around the
gore sale yards
we've expanded the industrial Zone
around mataro Valley milk in the North
we've introduced a new residential
Development Area and Gore West
we've got a town center Zone and Gore
expanded mixed-use Zone around the
outside of Gore
three residential zones that provide
large lot residential around the
outskirts of Gore
standard residential closer into the to
the township and then medium density
housing so
um
uh pretty cool like Terrace housing
style development in and around gawa
it's probably an overview for Gore and
if we move to the next slide I think
Victoria we're going to talk about
matara
yes yes
um
[Music]
if I can just just
but in there I think Victory you've got
a slightly different map I'll just show
you the councilors on the screen
to provide
slide that's good to go Victoria
cool thanks for that next slide
cool next steps uh July we're reporting
to council to notify now
appending that prepare Communications
and engagement material for notification
and then August aiming for public
notification at the end of August with
ongoing Communications and engagement
and then to confirm the hearings panel
we've sort of confirmed the structure of
that just not necessarily the
individuals yet September to December
submissions and then further submissions
with hearings happening early 2024.
any questions
counselors do you have any questions
John
just a couple
um under the designated areas they have
the schools all listed they have still
missed out at Armor School
I just wondering why
and then the other question was in the
discussion and our committees we had
setbacks of um it was one meter for
fencing and for fencing areas and we
discussed that to bring it up to two
meters that has not changed
um
I think
and just to query on the industrial area
in waikika where the transport is and
also the south end of waikaka has
changed from
um for industrial to sediment rules
rules of sediment
I just wonder why that's changed
so I'll answer the things I can answer
and then we'll hand over to the rest of
the team so in terms of the one meter
setback for vegetation clearance and the
significant natural areas for fencing
uh I thought what we discussed at the
committee a couple of weeks ago was that
we would
retain the one meter setback but enable
an easier consent path if you exceeded
that one meter and that's what is
provided for in the chapter now so if
you don't meet that one meter clearance
requirement
dinner it triggers out to a restricted
discretionary activity as opposed to a
full discretionary activity
so I'm happy to if I've got that wrong
uh happy to amend that but I thought
that's what the discussion was at the
last meeting
in terms of the otama school teeny you
might be best place to answer that in
terms of designations I think there's a
query about why it's missing from the
designation list
if you can clarify that one
in the waikika question maybe if we can
go Susan if we can go backwards to the
maps that we might try and clarify the
question about yeah
uh
yeah
so what sorry what what was the question
about just in the uh South End of
waikika
um if you look at that top Corner map
yeah
um at the bottom end it was classed as
industrial and also there's a transport
yard in the middle waikika and it's also
beside the school
should be classed as industrial too
or no it shouldn't be sediment raw
settlement
so are you saying at the moment it's
colored yellow and it should be pink
Industrial
um
Victoria or I don't know if we've got
Katrina back are you able to respond to
that question
you're sorry yeah sorry I just got up
the operative District um so now I can't
see any industrial zoning out that way
but I don't either 100 sure what you're
talking about but in the general by
Target area
so maybe Katrina are you able to explain
what the settlement Zone allows for in
terms of those existing uses
because I don't think the councilor
guidance question related to the
operative plan but to the draft that was
circulated
so it was the question that the draft
that was circulated had it colored
industrial and now it's gone back to
settlement yeah
okay Katrina can you can you look into
that and then
um
just give us a response after we've
taken a few more questions
thanks
Joe
uh three of you Mr chair
um there has also been previous
discussion about the fire break setbacks
from buildings
um it's still in there as being two
meters uh how are we addressing that
because that's pretty small for a loaded
vegetation area
so again that that it's the same as the
clearance of a fence lines it kicks up
to a simpler consent path
but from memory there's also
requirement or a rule that enables
there's an emergency works from memory
so I haven't got it in front of me yeah
just under Section 330 of the RMA so an
emergency situation so you could take
that but it wouldn't deal with
preemptive works
if I can assist my my recollection on
the discussion of houses
was the amount to be cleared around the
house is an issue that will come up only
when a new house is built which will
require a consent in any case
and at that time consideration can be
given and if they want more than the two
meters and from a fire protection point
of view right the notes say five to
seven is desirable
so depending on the features of the site
whether this vegetation there or not it
can be dealt with at the same time
um my recollection on the fencing issue
John was that
um we we talked about one and a half
meters each side
um has been an appropriate outcome to
include in the plan rather than a meter
so I think what what flow from Meadows
that the for the fencing rule the one
meter should read 1.5 each side
sure we can make that change yeah but I
I guess we've also made a change that if
you exceed the one and a half meters
it's a restricted discretionary activity
and if you exceed the two meters forward
um fire breaks it's also a restricted
discretionary activity and the matters
that Council or the planner can consider
includes things like
practicalities of doing the work and in
the case of fire breaks
um
you know the the risk associated with
not doing that so
John it still means to clear around an
existing building more than two meters
you'll need a consent
that's correct but it's a lower level
consent than than uh if you're not if
you're doing it somewhere else
any other questions comments
The Roots
poor
thank you
um let's just those other matters are
there in here it's outside the plan I
see but
the line bells ring when I see financial
assistance is offered
um number of matters is city outside the
district plan that need to be considered
by the council such as Financial
assistant for significant natural areas
and Heritage building sites is that
something we discuss now or is that
something tied up with the
Ed is it read we would need to bring a
report back to council to get direction
on those things but it's just
highlighting that uh Interstate would
need to take
so there are some things that will be
happening under the Local Government Act
provisions and some under the district
plan provisions and in the operative
plan and things like Financial
contributions were considered as part of
the plan but best practice now and
recognizing changes coming to the
resource management legislation it's
appropriate to split things like that
now out of the plan thank you
John
you're just the other thing I picked up
on
um is the setbacks on the river it's
been 20 meters on the material and
some some of my cake has got 20 meters
then it steps down to 10 meters and then
for your local Creeks it's five meters
and I just noticed that the fencing is
now classed as a structure
so you need a consent for fencing within
that area is that right now whereas I
thought fencing was not a structure
because would that be like a one more
offense would have to be consented
I think we've got an answer to your
first question so we'll deal with that
and we'll come back to the uh Tina you
might be able to deal with the fence as
a structure when it comes to stream
setbacks so Katrina do you want to cover
off the waikaka question
sure so
[Music]
um
activities
so those industrial activities will be
allowed to continue under existing use
rights but if new industrial activities
want to locate in those areas then
they'll need to get a low level consent
Tina have you got an answer in terms of
stream setbacks and whether fences or
structures and will require a consent if
they're within say five meters of a
string
yeah sure so
um the fence is a structure under the
definitions
um so if they would be captured in that
setback but obviously this aspect
changes depending on
um
there's a dream
so there is a smaller step back or for
the police as proposition
just to add to that Regional environment
Southland mentioned that they wanted
that aspect dealt with from a national
natural hazardous perspective just in
terms of collecting debris in their
streams so that was part of the
reasoning by purposely including that in
that setback
anything further from counselors
I just wanted to highlight for people
who may
be wondering why we have moved from a
district plan that's about 150 pages to
one that's 600 pages
and I'm afraid it's a sign of the times
probably as as highlighted we only had
several one rural Zone and several
residential zones which at the time the
district plan was prepared at
um the early 2000s was quite appropriate
and met the needs of the district now we
have far more complex legislation that
actually requires us to have these
numerous zones and and to have a
detailed more detailed policy framework
than what we've had in the past in
particular what's in the new plan is
providing for Meaningful growth in the
small townships and attempting to be
enabling appropriate growth in in areas
that's suitable to remove the need for
people to Lodge consents for things like
Camp Colombo the field day sites that
are now being recognized explicitly in
the town to give them more certainty and
enable them to plan ahead so from that
point of view the district plan is is a
significant step forward and providing
for the needs and ongoing development
potential of the district and I believe
that the plan in its present format will
provide an extremely useful tool moving
forward
I welcome the public submissions that
are lodged to the plan while there has
been one opportunity informally to make
comment the public submission process is
a formal process that enables all
interests any person to be involved and
to contribute to finalizing the document
while it has been a significant process
over the last five years involving a
number of consultants and thank you to
the team but also many of the staff here
in the building providing backup and to
the councilors who have also contributed
I'd say thank you we however probably
have another 15 16 months ahead before
we were able to issue the decisions on
the plan I see it as the second most
important document that this Council
will prepare during this triennium with
the long-term plan being the most
significant and so today is really a an
important day in terms of what we as
elected officials are providing for The
Wider Community to move forward in a
beneficial way
we have a three recommendations that are
on the table firstly and I think we can
deal with them together that the report
and supporting information be received
that the district plan is accepted for
public notification and that the review
and
that the review and authorization of
minor corrections to the proposed
District plan be delegated to the chair
of the district Clan subcommittee do I
have a mover of those motions please
well one more question yes Stuart just
to met for those setbacks they legal sit
backs or we just make them for those 20
meters tier and five
are they in legislation somewhere or
they just made up
um
Tina do you want to kind of give a bit
of an overview of where they came from
because we've looked at other plans and
drawn on those and also the
from memory The Strain type as well
and yeah it is trying to
find him so that
it's best practice
oh sorry it just makes the
anything you do around them this become
a Wilderness Area on people's properties
then and
if you can't if you have to fence back
so far you can't get a digger near the
edge of a tree or something becomes
lodged in there it just gets left in the
creek and I've just seen it happen with
massive erosion down a creek and sloped
down because no one does anything with
the edge of the creek because they can't
get a digger in there to pull something
out a big flood comes and the next thing
there's a huge hunk of land washed away
so you need
keep your fences in the grazing up to
those edges as close as possible without
damaging anything
uh to give
clearance when the river floods if they
have Bush and stuff alongside it just
washes out huge hunks of the Riverbanks
and
well at the same time we have initiative
some place to encourage Farmers to be
planting the margins of our waterways to
cut down on the amount of silt and other
material entering them so uh yeah
there's a to each sword there in terms
of pros and cons uh Joe and then John
uh thank you Mr chair
um just in relation to point to on the
recommendation that the proposed
District plan was accepted for public
notification the process around that I
have had
um
a constitution antenna area talk to me
about the initial consultation about the
change to light industrial slash
industrial south of Gore here
they are just worried about the level of
notification I'm just wondering what the
process is and whether they could get a
letter in the mail or some sort of email
targeting them and those people specific
in those areas saying know what's
happening so yeah I can give you a bit
more detail about what we're planning in
terms of notification so anybody who's
provided feedback to date on the draft
District plan will get a letter directly
uh indicating that the plan is going to
be notified and and so they'll be
contacted directly so in that area I
believe we did get a lot of feedback
from the landowners and the neighbors so
they will be notified directly if you
like and as part of notification of a
district then we need to send letters to
every
resident in the district as well so
everyone will have an opportunity
there'll be an ad in the paper as well
John
I was just going to comment on Stuart's
comment again that and the last plan
many years ago I was in Frederick
farmers and I fought vividly for a
lesser setback than what they had and we
had it for many years and we had no
trouble and now we're back to square one
we'll take that as a comment
Neville I thought you Mr chair
um I've no question just that I'd like
to
um move those recommendations all three
thank you we have a second there for the
motion
Paul thank you
any further comment
discussion
so I'll put the three motions all those
in favor say aye
aye against
carried
thank you everybody that is a
significant step forward
that brings us to the end of the agenda
so I will close the meeting thank you
very much
foreign